para algunos es un héroe cibernético que
denunció los abusos de poder del
gobierno para otros es un delincuente
que socavó la seguridad de occidente
julian assange nació en townsville
australia en 1971 cuando era adolescente
demostró unas habilidades informáticas
excepcionales penetrando varios sistemas
seguros incluidos los de la nasa y el
pentágono pero fue finalmente capturado
y consiguió evitar la cárcel con la
condición de no reincidir en 2006
assange fundó wikileaks la web de
denuncias llegó a los titulares
internacionales en 2010 cuando filtró
información de chelsea manning un
analista de la inteligencia del ejército
estadounidense
la publicación incluía un vídeo de un
helicóptero estadounidense disparando
contra civiles iraquíes y matando a una
docena de personas entre ellas dos
periodistas de reuters
escoger
está claro que esto dará forma a la
comprensión de lo que han sido los
últimos seis años de guerra y de que el
curso de la misma debe cambiar
desde entonces wikileaks ha revelado
cientos de miles de archivos militares
secretos y cables diplomáticos los
partidarios de assange lo ven como un
símbolo de la libertad de expresión que
responsabiliza a los gobiernos por sus
acciones pero sus críticos dicen que
puso en peligro a fuentes e informantes
en zonas de guerra al filtrar a material
clasificado su reputación sufrió un
golpe en 2016 en el período previo a las
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu cuando
wikileaks publicó correos electrónicos
relacionados con la campaña de la
demócrata hillary clinton algunos
funcionarios estadounidenses creen que
fue parte de una operación de
inteligencia rusa para perjudicar las
elecciones e impulsar la candidatura
presidencial de donald trump
assange también se ha posicionado a
favor del break city y recibió en la
embajada de ecuador en ángel ferrant
aliado de ground y defensor de un
acercamiento con rusia fue en la
embajada donde se refugió entre 2012 y
hasta que fue detenido por la policía
británica por violar su libertad
condicional desde entonces está
arrestado en la prisión de máxima
seguridad de belmarsh donde enfrentó con
éxito una solicitud de extradición de
eeuu en enero pero permaneció en
custodia a la espera de la apelación